meine mutter sagt immer ich soll lech
und ein grinsen auf setzen
[Musik]
sie hat gesagt ich hätte eine bestimmung
lachen und freude in die welt zu bringen
[Musik]
diese woche kommt in deutschland den
film ins kino auf den wahrscheinlich
mehr leute gewartet haben als auch die
meisten anderen titel in diesem kinojahr
joker von todd phillips
warum ist das so ein ereignis hätte ich
mir das nur ein oder hört sich wer das
recht hat schon zahlreiche geschichten
mit dem joker
man kennt ihn im grunde man weiß was für
die figur das ist und dort philips hat
es nun unternommen zu dieser figur noch
einmal froh dass wir eine gründungs
erzählung zu verfassen
da hilft es dir jemanden zum reden zu
haben
wir lernen noch einmal man könnte sagen
von vom punkt null an kennen wer das
reich ist dieser joker affelay
westermann und dem die regel ist es ein
clown im top ten ziele mit dieser
spannung spielt der film von beginn an
ganz bekommt sie dabei von den ersten
szenen an dass er das eigentlich nicht
drauf hat er es niemals der seite zum
lachen bringt
fast entsetzlich oder von anfang an
beklemmend wie weniger dazu in der lage
ist heiterkeit zu erregen
am ende muss aus diesem alter fleck der
joker geworden sein
[Gelächter]
was ist so lustig
die muss die figur stehen die dann in
das comic universum eintritt und
tatsächlich ist das hier dann auch ein
bisschen so dass sie aus einem noch bei
einer realistischen allerdings
filmhistorisch sehr stark montierten new
york in eine andere welt daneben in die
welt der comics eintritt ist unser
belästigt
er legt auch viel mist deutliche spuren
aus mit denen er zeigt an welchem kino
er selber sich orientieren möchte es
gibt eine klare verweise auf martin
scorcese im grunde ist der ganze joker
jetzt aus dem jahr 2009 10 eine große
ehrenerklärung eine große hommage an den
frühlings esel namens cortese vom mit
streets natürlich einen scorsese taxi
driver denn mit dieser figur als taxi
driver hat diese figur von aflac eine
menge zu tun
die zocker hat in venedig vor wenigen
wochen beim eric wir haben 50 jahren
wurde dort auch mit
das hat viele überrascht mit einem
goldenen löwen ausgezeichnet
ich habe ausschließlich negative
gedanken
ich bin das bekommen herausgekommen
man kann sich diesen eindruck dieser
vision dieses albtraumhaften da schwer
einziehen
dazu kommt eine sehr starke musik per
kamera selbst design alles ist wirklich
von und dazu kommt eben diese
schauspielerische leistung und joaquin
phoenix für meine begriffe für ein
schauspieler der immer an der grenze
agiert zwischen einer wirklich taten
präsenz aber aber das ist eben hier auch
in der figur angelegt
doch auch immer mit einer tendenz ins
groteske und ich glaube hier diese
gratwanderung ist wirklich sehr sehr
interessant für meine tägliche da doch
immer wieder auch ein bisschen zu weit
und insel ist easy rungen aber das
gehört eben auch zum konzept der film
ist in hohem maße stilisiert mein ganzes
leben
[Musik]
nicht klar ob ich überhaupt existiert
es gab nun auch schon recht kritische
reaktionen vor allem in den usa und ich
verstehe ganz gut warum das so ist es
erfragen wir ein kollege vom new yorker
hat philips im grunde rassismus
vorgeworfen
das hat mit inszenierung einige der
untaten von jokers zu tun was sagen
manche leute dass sie liebst als
politischen aspekte die rassistischen
aspekte heraus genommen hat um das
gewicht zu lassen weiß gewaschen hätte
an diesen vorwürfen ist tatsächlich auch
etwas dran man sieht schon sehr stark
dass der film in new york oder ein gott
im city zeigen möchte dass eben doch für
das immer noch dominierende blockbuster
publikum zuerst einmal aufbereitet wird
das sind nun einmal um ähnliche weise
jugendliche diese ganzen
differenzierungs prozesse diesem moment
rolle wurde im gange sind sieht man
eigentlich beim joker relativ wenig
angedeutet in dieser hinsicht ist ja
auch anachronistisch bis zu einem
gewissen dafür eine sache nach wenn sie
mich ankündigen
wir haben sie mich hat circa vorstellen
so dass als gesamteindruck ein
zwiespältiger bleibt ein düsteres
meisterwerk ein politisch fragwürdige
film irgendwann ein zentraler film in
diesem jahr